>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT" ."
IT'S MONDAY, WE JUST HAD A
VACATION SO WE ARE TRYING TO
THINK A LITTLE MORE BROADLY
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THIS
WORLD.
HERE'S WHAT WE COME UP WITH, YOU
HAD TO BOIL DOWN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S LONG-TERM
GOALS TO THE MOST IMPORTANT
GOALS, THE FIRST WOULD BE THIS,
AND IT'S OBVIOUS, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE TWO COLOR THE
ESSENTIALS OF LIFE FOR MOST
PEOPLE.
HEALTH CARE, COLLEGE, HOUSING,
FOOD, IN SOME CASES A GUARANTEED
BASIC INCOME.
THAT'S THE PROGRAM WITH THE
DEMOCRATS ESPOUSE, ANOTHER WORD
FOR IT MIGHT BE SOCIALISM.
THE PARTY'S OTHER LONG-TERM
GOALS IS THE ELIMINATION OF
MEANINGFUL RESTRICTIONS ON
IMMIGRATION INTO THIS COUNTRY.
GET RID OF ICE, EXCEPT MOST
REFUGEES, CITIZENSHIP TO TENS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY, IN OTHER WORDS, OPEN
BORDERS.
SO THOSE OF THE DEMOCRATS MAIN
PRIORITIES, MASSIVE SOCIAL
WELFARE STATE AND CITIZENS FROM
THE THIRD WORLD.
NOBODY IS HIDING THAT I'M A THEY
ARE SAYING IT OUT LOUD.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THOSE TWO
GOALS CONFLICT WITH EACH OTHER.
YOU CAN EITHER ADMIT THE WORLD'S
POOR INTO YOUR COUNTRY OR YOU
CAN GIVE YOUR OWN PEOPLE MORE
FREE STUFF, BUT YOU CAN'T DO
BOTH.
THE MATH DOESN'T WORK.
SOCIALISM WITH OPEN BORDERS IS
IMPOSSIBLE.
IT HAS NEVER WORKED AND IT NEVER
WILL WORK.
NOBODY THINKS ABOUT THAT FOR
ABOUT A MINUTE UNDERSTANDS IT.
SO THE IDEA IS FATALLY FLAWED.
THE QUESTION IS, HOW DO YOU SELL
A PROGRAM THAT CAN EVER ACTUALLY
WORK?
YOU LIE ABOUT IT, YOU PRETEND
THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY TRUE ISN'T
TRUE AT ALL AND YOU ARE EVIL FOR
THINKING OTHERWISE.
AND OF COURSE THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THEY ARE DOING NOW.
WATCH DNC SPOKESMAN JIM ACOSTA
FROM EARLIER THIS MONTH IT'S
CALLED THE PRESIDENT FOR DARING
TO SUGGEST THAT MIGRANTS FROM
THE IMAGINARY CARAVAN, SHOULD IT
ACTUALLY EXISTS MIGHT TRY TO
HELP THE U.S. BORDER.
>> YOUR CAMPAIGN HAD AN AD
SHOWING MIGRANTS CLIMBING OVER
WALLS.
>> THEY WEREN'T ACTORS.
IT WAS TRUE.
DO YOU THINK THEY WERE ACTORS?
THEY DIDN'T COME FROM HOLLYWOOD.
>> Tucker: THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO BE DOING THAT, SAYS
DEMOCRATIC FLACH JIM ACOSTA.
TURNS OUT THAT'S PRECISELY WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOING AND
JUST DID OVER THE WEEKEND.
AMERICAN AUTHORITIES HAD TO SHUT
DOWN THE BORDER CROSSING IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NEXT TO
SAN DIEGO AFTER ABOUT A THOUSAND
PEOPLE TRY TO RUSH THE CROSSING.
WATCH.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Tucker: SO THAT'S WHAT THE
DNC CHANNELS TOLD US WERE NEVER
GOING TO HAPPEN AND COURSE IT
DID HAPPEN.
IT WAS BAD.
MEXICAN RIGHT POLICE AND U.S.
BORDER AGENTS BOTH CAME UNDER
ATTACK FROM THE MOB, WHICH THREW
ROCKS AT THEM.
WITH NO MEANINGFUL WALL ALONG
THE BORDERS THEY USED TEAR GAS
TO DISPERSE THE CROWD.
THERE IS FAIRLY RECENT PRECEDENT
FOR DOING THAT.
IN 2013 A GROUP OF ABOUT 100
PEOPLE TRY TO RUSH THE VERY SAME
BORDER CROSSING.
AMERICAN AUTHORITIES FORCED THEM
BACK WITH PEPPER SPRAY.
BARACK OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT AT
THE TIME.
THE INCIDENT PASSED WITH LITTLE
NOTICE.
JUST FIVE YEARS LATER THERE IS A
NEW PRESIDENT AND IN AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT STANDARD.
THE LEFT ERUPTED AT THESE
PICTURES OF THE TEAR GAS AND
ACCUSED THE ADMINISTRATION OF
MORAL ATROCITIES.
HAWAII SENATOR GOT SO WORKED UP
THAT HE SUGGESTED AMERICAN
AUTHORITIES HAD COMMITTED A WAR
CRIME BY USING ILLEGAL CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
KEEP IN MIND THE SAME SO-CALLED
CHEMICAL WEAPONS ARE USED
AGAINST UNRULY AMERICAN CITIZENS
ALL THE TIME AND NOBODY CARES.
BUT THOSE WEREN'T AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHO JUST SAW GETTING
TEARGAS OVER THE WEEKEND, THEY
WERE MIGRANTS, THEY WERE HOLY
MEN ON A SACRED PILGRIMAGE
NORTH.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM WAS
INEXCUSABLE, Q THE MORAL OUTRAG
OUTRAGE.
>> HERE WE LOOK AT CHILDREN
BEING SUBJECTED TO TEARGAS,
THAT'S THE UNITED STATES CAUSING
THAT, THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> WE HAVE SEEN THE IMAGES OF
THE CHILDREN AND THE WOMEN AND
THERE HAS GOT TO BE A PRAGMATIC
AND COMPASSIONATE ANSWER HERE
THAT DOES NOT INVOLVE TEARGAS
AND CHILDREN.
THAT IS NOT WHO AMERICA IS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT WHAT
AMERICA IS DECLARE SOME RANDOM
BLOWHARD ON CNN WHO HAS SOMEHOW
BEEN DEPUTIZED TO LECTURE YOU
ABOUT WHAT AMERICA IS.
ON THE LEFT, AMERICA IS ALWAYS
ONE THING FOR SURE, IN EVERY
CASE, WRONG.
WATCH AS THIS MSNBC GUEST
SUGGEST THAT FEDERAL BORDER
PATROL AGENTS MUST'VE BEEN LYING
ABOUT BEING ATTACKED WITH ROCKS.
>> THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
ANYBODY THREW ROCKS.
NPR WAS REPORTING IT WAS
RELATIVELY PEACEFUL.
>> Tucker: RELATIVELY PEACEFUL
EXCEPT FOR THIS SCENE WHICH
SOMEHOW DIDN'T MAKE IT INTO MANY
NEWS REPORTS.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Tucker: SO, WELL, YES IT
TURNS OUT THEY WERE IN FACT
THROWING ROCKS BUT ACCORDING TO
A LOT OF THE ANALYSIS YOU MAY
HAVE SEEN TODAY IT WAS IN A
PEACEFUL WAY, GENTLE ROCK
THROWING.
WILLIE MOORE TOSSING AND
THROWING, PLAYFUL ACTUALLY.
THERE'S A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE,
FROM SOMEONE WHO WAS ACTUALLY
THERE AND IN CONTRAST TO THE
PEOPLE YOU JUST SAW, IS NOT A
PROFESSIONAL PROPAGANDIST.
>> CHALLENGE THAT THIS WAS A
PEACEFUL PROTEST OR THE MAJORITY
OF THESE PEOPLE WERE CLAIMING
ASYLUM.
WE ENDED UP MAKING ABOUT 40 TO
ARREST.
ONLY EIGHT OF THOSE WERE FEMALES
AND THERE WERE ONLY A FEW
CHILDREN INVOLVED.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WE
ARE DEALING WITH OUR ADULT
MALES.
ONE OF THE GROUPS I WATCH,
SEVERAL OF THEM WERE ARRESTED,
THEY PASSED TEN OR 15 UNITS
WALKING WEST TO EAST.
NUMEROUS UNIFORMED PERSONNEL AND
THEY WERE CHANTING, WAVING A
HONDURAN FLAG AND THROWING ROCKS
AT THE AGENTS.
IF THEY WERE TRULY
ASYLUM-SEEKERS THAT WOULD'VE
JUST WALKED UP WITH THEIR HANDS
UP AND SURRENDERED AND THAT DID
NOT TAKE PLACE.
WHAT I FIND UNCONSCIONABLE IS
PEOPLE WOULD INTENTIONALLY TAKE
CHILDREN INTO THIS SITUATION.
WHAT WE SAW OVER AND OVER
YESTERDAY WAS THE GROUP, THE
CARAVAN, AS WE CALL THEM, WOULD
PUSH WOMEN AND CHILDREN TOWARDS
THE FRONT AND THEN BEGIN
BASICALLY ROCKING OUR AGENTS.
>> Tucker: THERE YOU HAVE, WE
WILL LET YOU REACH YOUR OWN
CONCLUSIONS ABOUT WHO'S TELLING
THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
CHECK THE VIDEO BEFORE YOU MAKE
UP YOUR MIND BUT AS YOU PONDER
IT, STEP BACK AND ASK YOURSELF
SOME MORE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS.
IS THERE A NATURAL LIMIT TO THIS
KIND OF IMMIGRATION?
HOW MANY RESOURCES DOES AMERICA
REALLY HAVE TWO SHARE WITH THE
REST OF THE WORLD?
ARE WE AS RICH AS WE ASSUME WE
ARE?
ARE YOU?
HOW MANY POOR PEOPLE CAN WE
REALISTICALLY ACCEPT BEFORE WE
ARE NOT THAT RICH AT ALL BUT
INCREASINGLY RESEMBLED THE
COUNTRIES FROM WHICH THESE
PEOPLE ARE FLEEING?
IF ACCEPTING MORE POOR PEOPLE
WILLIE MAKES A MORE PROSPEROUS,
THEN WHAT EXACTLY HAS HAPPENED
IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE PAST 30
YEARS, WHICH DESPITE RECORD
LEVELS OF IMMIGRATION, IS POORER
THAN EVER?
IT'S POSSIBLE THERE ARE GOOD
ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS,